Es ist wirklich eine
Absolute sensation seit gestern hat ein neues zeitalter der astronomie begonnen denn gestern ging es um die welt am 17 august
Fand ein ganz besonderes ereignis
Im universum stand und zum aller ersten mal konnte es parallel mit dem fermi satelliten und dem
gravitationswellen detektor lego in den usa beobachtet werden die kollision zweier neutronensterne
Konnte so auf nie dagewesene art und weise analysiert werden warum das alles ändert in der astronomie
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es war der erste beitrag hier bei pixum science fiction es ging
Um den stärksten gamma ray burst den stärksten gamma blitz aller zeiten er traf die erde am 27 april
2013 gott sei dank war die quelle
3,6 milliarden lichtjahre entfernt er war aber so stark dass
Er den messbereich der satelliten fermi der gamma ray burst untersucht überschritten hat trotzdem
Konnte, er der erde nichts anhaben er war viel zu weit entfernt das war wohl nicht immer
So die astrophysik vermutet hinter einem gamma blitz den grund für ein massensterben vor
443 millionen jahren auf der erde und jetzt wurde wieder ein ganz besonderer gamma ray burst beobachtet er war nicht
So stark wie der gamma blitz 2013 und auch wieder weit entfernt aber zum ersten mal wurde er nicht nur von ferne
beobachtet und gemessen sondern auch von gravitationswellen direkt
In den usa am 17 august 2017 um 14 uhr 41 minuten und vier sekunden
mitteleuropäischer sommerzeit
detektierten beide auf ganz
unterschiedliche art und weise das gleiche ereignis wobei ist ein minimal
zeitversatz von zwei sekunden gab der noch erforscht werden muss zwei nummern hat dieses ereignis deshalb zum einen die
grb 17 und 8 17 wobei ihr grb für gamma ray burst steht also der gamma wellen ausbruch und gw
1717 wobei gebe hierfür
Gravitation wave also gravitationswellen steht und diese fast gleichzeitige messung ist etwas ganz besonderes und ändert alles erstmals sind es
gravitationswellen die nicht von der kollision zweier schwarzer löcher stammen wo also nicht zu sehen ist damit bietet sich nämlich die möglichkeit
Dieses ereignis auch noch anders zu beobachten weil es eben etwas
zu sehen gibt nämlich dessen elektromagnetische strahlung das heißt gammastrahlung in ultraviolette strahlung licht
Infrarote strahlung und radiowellen damit gibt es daten die so bisher nicht vorlage und bereits die erste bahnbrechende
erkenntnis zitat dies ist der erste eindeutige nachweis einer verschmelzung zweier neutronensterne
das sagt delfzijl erforscht beim national radio astronomy
operator in den usa und werkhallen vom california institute of technology
Erklärt die geschichte die wir hier beobachten ist damit vollständiger als jedes andere ereignisse in der astronomie geschichte
Mit den informationen die sowohl die gravitationswellen als auch die
Elektromagnetische strahlung liefern können wir dasselbe ereignis erstmals sowohl hören als auch see
Und das ist das wirklich umwerfende kurz nachdem das signal von neigung gefunden wurde wurde die nachricht an zahlreiche teleskope und
forschungseinrichtungen weitergeleitet die richteten ihre teleskope weltweit in richtung
Des ursprungs der gravitationswellen aus nach elf stunden wurde das
Teleskop in chile fündig wir sahen eine. Helle bläuliche lichtquelle in einer nahegelegenen galaxie, so josh samen von der carnegie institution
war
insgesamt waren es dann 70 observatorien inklusive dem hubble-weltraumteleskop
Die das nachglühen in den verschiedenen wellen bereichen tage lang beobachtet haben es wird wirklich spannend wenn es dann noch ab nächstem jahr
das riesige james webb, weltraumteleskop
auf solche ereignisse gerichtet werden kann dann wird es voraussichtlich unglaubliche bilder
Und neue erkenntnisse gehen mega spannend wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mehr
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit dem video zum stärksten blitz aller zeiten wird ein gamma blitz die erde zerstört der hellste
blitz aller zeiten das erste video von klicks und science fiction schon witzig wie alles begann also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran